magic I I'm a little surprised with the
advent of magic I technology in the 90s
society didn't divide itself Huxley like
into the elite overlords able to see the
3d dolphins and gloves and the
subservient underclass able only to see
a mishmash of colored pixels I suppose
it's hard to rule civilization when
you've got a massive headache from
looking at optical illusions all the
time at any rate as one of the
genetically superior dolphin Sears I
like to tell the less visually gifted
that it was all just a trick there was
nothing to see in the first place it
makes them so happy B+ vase or faces the
problem with this exercise in which you
see either a single lovely vase or a
pair of faces is once you start seeing
negative space profiles it's hard to
stop and given that most vases aren't
designed with visual ambiguity in mind
that means that suddenly you start
seeing horrible homunculus everywhere
these these deformed creatures with
sloping foreheads and tumorous chins
cratenbarrel stores become terrifying
dens of mutated humanity while still
remaining very very boring c- grid with
dots okay if you look at a grid of black
squares you see fuzzy little dots at the
intersection well yay I'm sure that was
an incredibly entertaining diversion
back when the only other distraction was
watching Papa died of the flux but my
mind demands a much more thorough
boggling if femoral navel lint hanging
out at street corners like 50 0 street
punks just doesn't do it for me unless
they carried switchblades and started
singing show tunes that'd be a pretty
impressive illusion d Penrose stairs
more popularly known as those stairs in
that one MC Escher drawing with all the
stairs this is a staircase that appears
to go up forever you know you really
have to give as your credit it wasn't
enough room to just draw illusions you
made them look like really old expensive
European hotels you check in you give
your bags to the bellhop you spend two
weeks climbing an endless
out of stairs then go home and tell your
friends oh you have to go I feel so much
more worldly now like I've really grown
as a person a old lady or young girl I
see the young girl immediately although
I do wonder why she has an ostrich
feather embedded in her head for years I
thought that the old lady was in her
enormous deformity hiding head tarp
looking kind of pained and having to
keep rain in an apartment window slop
off a young girl's head but no that
would have been young girl and old lady
in twisted symbiosis as it turns out the
old lady is made up of the young girls
chin and ear and she still has an old
lady in her head Tarb see